so today we're revisiting the painters
paradox
briefly mentioned on the channel before
but this time we're gonna we're gonna do
the maths we're gonna crunch through it
and we're gonna show this amazing
paradox that you can have
in this infinitely long horn which you
can fill with paint
but you can never paint the surface
because the surface area
is infinite and we're going to crunch
through the equations the maths
to see how it all works and exactly why
this is what happens
[Music]
okay so to form this uh this infinite
horm
called gabriel's horn uh what we
actually do is
create a shape which is called a volume
or a surface of revolution
and we're going to draw the graph of y
equals one over x
so as x goes really small it shoots off
to infinity
and as x gets bigger and bigger and
bigger we've got one over that
so that's going to go and decay down to
zero
and then what we do first of all is
we're gonna just chop it here
at one so this is at x equals one so y
is also
one here as well so now we've got this
still infinitely long graph and then
we're gonna take it and we're going to
rotate
it around the x-axis
it's basically like a big venezuela from
the world cup in 2010
if you have an old-school reference but
it's one of those big long tubes
where you're blowing down the idea is of
course this is infinite
now this is is gabriel's horn i'm
assuming that comes from the archangel
gabriel yes so i think it does i think
this is called gabriel's horn because
the archangel gabe was often pictured
with a really long horn but this is
infinite it is important to remember
that this horn goes forever
but of course it's going to be
infinitesimally small
as it like you're going to no longer be
able to see it it's going to be that
small as you carry on
gabriel must have a very small mouth
that's right
yeah if he's blowing in the small head
exactly
first of all let's figure out the volume
of the shape i would have thought it
would have an infinite volume because
it never gets to a point where there's
not a little bit of hollowness
that would be a perfectly reasonable
thing to assume because it goes forever
there's always something there so surely
it's volume is also influenced it can
always take just a little bit more paint
this is why i wanted to go through this
right because the paradox itself
it's called a paradox because if you try
to think about it
using our intuition it kind of doesn't
make sense that's literally why it's a
paradox but then
of course we do have the mathematical
tools to give us the definitive answer
that almost like can't be argued with so
you might not believe what you get but
you can't really argue with the mats
and that's what we're going to hopefully
figure out now there's a formula for a
volume of revolution and some of you may
know this
you do learn it at school but we're
going to kind of think about where it
comes from by actually
looking at the shape so we will end up
with the same formula but let's think
about like intuitively how do we figure
out the volume of this
so we're going to need to do an integral
just like when an integral underneath
the curve gives you an area
underneath that curve so here we're
going to do an integral to get the
volume the way we normally do
the area under a curve when you do an
integral is you imagine splitting it up
into loads of really thin strips and
then you add together all of those
strips
as their width goes to zero that's
basically calculus this is what newton
and leibniz did they came up with this
whole concept we do the same thing here
but we're going to slice through
and get little pieces of the horn so 3d
pieces it's going to kind of look like a
cylinder it's not going to quite be a
perfect cylinder because there's going
to be a little bit of a slant
on the edge but if you make these strips
really thin
it's going to get closer and closer to a
cylinder
[Music]
so what we do is we say this slice along
the x-axis is going to be width
dx so this is where it's going to come
into our integral this is a small
bit along the x-axis and the thinner it
is
the closer those two circles are to
being the same exactly
yes and we are eventually through the
integral process we will
let this width go to zero that's what an
integral is taking
that limiting process rather than just a
sum where you add them together
so this is the height of our cylinder so
the volume of a cylinder is just equal
to
the area of the face multiplied by its
height
by its depth so we know the area of a
circle it's going to be pi
times the radius squared and then we're
going to multiply
by the height dx so the volume of this
cylinder
is pi radius squared times its height dx
so now if we just add together all of
these cylinders
and then let dx the width go to zero
that will give us our integral the final
volume of
gabriel's horn is going to be the
integral so we're starting from one
and we're going all the way down here to
infinity tending to infinity
so we're starting from one to infinity
that's our limits of our integration
we've got pi we've got the radius
squared
and then we integrate with respect to dx
so this is the formula
that perhaps you may have seen before or
a volume of revolution but it comes from
these little pieces of cylinders being
added together now the radius
so if we look back at our picture and
i've drawn this really badly and not
very symmetrically
but if this was if this is the central
point and it's the same
on either side the radius is exactly
that distance from the axis up to the
curve and you can see that depending on
where you take your slice you get
different values of the radius you're
gonna get bigger circles up here
and really really tiny circles down here
so the actual radius
the distance from the line to the graph
well that's just given by
the value of y because you're starting
at y equals naught and you're going up
to this point
here which is y some value so the radius
r is actually equal to the value of y
but y is 1 over x
because it was our graph that we had so
the radius
is one over x so we can now plug this
into our formula
and we've got an integral which we can
take the pi outside
one to infinity and then we've got one
over x squared
dx now that is an integral we can do if
you've done any
high school calculus we've got x to the
minus 2. so if i do that integral i get
minus
1 over x with my two limits
and then i plug in the two values so
it's now pi multiplied by
minus one over infinity well one over
infinity that's zero
so you get nothing from that and then
it's minus
minus one over one so it's one so the
volume
of gabriel's horn is pi
which in itself is nice it's always nice
when pi
just appears out of nowhere so if we
take the graph
of y equals one over x rotate it around
the x-axis to form this
infinite horn the volume is equal to pi
amazing in itself but for our purposes
we didn't really care what this was as
long as it wasn't infinity
because this is a finite number so i can
go out now and buy
pie units of paint i can fill
gabriel's horde with pie units of paint
and it will be completely filled with
paint
and there's can't fit anymore it can't
be any less that's just that's it
now the surface area same kind of idea
we we want to think about what happens
when we have a small piece
of the horn and then now instead of
thinking about its volume
we want to think about the area around
the edge so the surface area of the
shape sort of going around
and around and around and around so
imagine like trying to wrap the whole
thing in toilet roll
for example if we were to slice through
the horn
you get something that looks like this
not quite a cylinder it's got like a
slant
and then you have the big circle at this
end which would be coming from up
sort of this end of it and then the
smaller one down here so you have
something like this
and now for the surface area you have
the reason you kind of this prop really
helps is
when you open this out it's like a part
of a circle
annulus would be the technical term but
it's like a sector of a circle isn't it
with the middle bit kind of chopped away
i like a pizza crust
it looks like a pizza crust doesn't it
the area of this
again if i put it together is going to
be the surface area
of our shape this particular shape is
actually the net
of something called a conical frostum
which is a rather ridiculous name but
that's what it's called
it looks kind of rude but anyway it does
frosted yeah
a conical frostum pizza crust and
conical frustrates
so this is the the shape and this we do
have a formula for the area
of this particular shape so what we need
to know to figure this out
is you need to know two things this
length and you also need to know
this length so let's call this one a and
this one b
do you not need to know an angle or any
other thing about the the nature of the
curve
no it's literally just it's just you
just a times b
um because what kind of half so if you
were to sort of
extend it and then think of this as a
sector of your circle with some angle
theta
it just so happens that the theta's kind
of all come out
but you can go through it and you'll get
that it is just a times b
in this particular surprise it's so
simple but there you go
i didn't believe it and i went through
this after about four pages of algebra
it works so i'll save you the the uh
agony of redoing that so now let's go
back
and think back to our curve this bit b
along the top this is actually going to
be this bit here isn't it as they join
together
this bit like along here there is a
slant here
so this thing along here we're going to
say this is about a straight line
again we're going to shrink this thing
down we say this is about a straight
line and we're going to call this
uh ds we use a different variable
because it's not horizontal this time
the slant here is important which is why
this was curved instead of just being a
rectangle which it would be for a
cylinder so the slant here is important
again it's a little bit technical
exactly why the slant is important
it's to do with taylor expansions and
lots of algebra
but the slant here matters for the
surface area so we know that we're going
to call that ds
and then this bit a well this is that
circle there
it's the circle around the bit of the
horn and of course
that's the circumference of a circle the
circumference of a circle
is equal to two pi times the radius
and again we showed here the radius is
just given by
y which is one over x because the radius
is the distance
from the axis to the shape itself so
what we've got then
is the piece of surface area
here is going to just be given by
so sa for surface area we're going to
have to integrate
with respect to ds and we'll worry about
that in a moment
and then we just multiply ds by 2 pi r
which is a times b so 2 pi we could
write
r but we know r is 1 over x so we're
going to just write that
as 1 over x so this is going to give us
our surface area now this pesky ds so
the way to deal with that
we look at what's going on over here d s
is it's kind of a straight line
and then if i were to turn this into a
triangle
like this then we've got d s
here call that right angle so this
horizontal direction
well that's along the x-axis as i'm
moving horizontally this is the x-axis
so this is dx
a small change on the x-axis and this is
vertical so this is d y
so we can now actually write good old
pythagoras theorem he's got our back
ds squared is going to be equal to dx
squared plus dy squared
okay so then what if i square root
so ds is now the square root of dx
squared plus dy squared we only take the
positive one because it's a distance
it's got to be positive i'm going to do
this pretty rough and ready you can do
this properly with a limiting process
so what you do is you kind of factor out
the dx
so you say right well if i take the dx
out here so it's come out the square
root so it was a dx squared inside
so i'm taking out a dx that leaves me
with one plus
d y by dx squared
so this is actually a derivative i've
kind of treated them like they were
fractions you can do this properly with
limits
again i'm doing it rough and ready
because we just want the result
so what we now got then is we can this
is now in terms of y
and x which is what we wanted because we
know those we know for example we know
that y is 1 over
x so dy by dx
is minus 1 over x squared
differentiating that function
the other good thing that we've got from
this is when we had ds we didn't know
what our limits were
because what is s it's just the distance
along the curve
we didn't know where to integrate
between but now we've actually turned d
s into
something with respect to x so again
we're going to go from the limits on x
which are from one
all the way to infinity so finally we've
got the integral we can take the two pi
outside
and then we've got the integral from one
to infinity
of one over x multiplied by d s
which is the square root of one plus d y
by d x squared
so that's square that i get one over x
to the four
dx so we get this pretty awful looking
integral
now we're not going to do this integral
we could do this integral you you can
use
trigonometric substitutions you can even
throw in a hyperbolic function if you
really want but we don't even need to do
that because
we kind of know what we're aiming for
and we know that this based on the
paradox this is going to go to infinity
so if we can show this is bigger than
infinity then it's infinity
it's a really good tactic when you have
an idea that something is going to be
infinity
show that it's bigger than something
else that's really common that we know
is definitely infinity
because if you're bigger than infinity
you're infinity i've got this function
here
the square root of 1 plus 1 over x to
the fourth
and i know that x is between 1 and
infinity
so that's to take a value between 1
infinity so whatever value of x i plug
in here
this whole thing is always bigger than
1 because if i if i plug in x is 1
i get the square root of 2 that's bigger
than one and then as x gets bigger and
bigger and bigger
this spit i'm adding above one gets
smaller
but it never quite gets to one so this
whole thing is definitely bigger
than one so let's just replace it and
say well
so the surface area is bigger than
two pi times the integral from one to
infinity
of one over x dx so we've really just
replaced that whole horrible square root
by
one and this is still true this is an
integral we can do again
so this is just 2 pi integral of 1 over
x
is the natural log of x between infinity
and 1
the natural log of infinity
is infinity so we didn't need to do the
horrible integral
because we can show that the surface
area is greater than
something that goes to infinity so the
surface area
is infinite
gabriel's horn where we take one over x
rotate around the axis to create
really infinitely long horn we can fill
it
with pi units of paint but
we can never paint the surface
because the surface area is infinite
and that is the painters paradox and
you're talking about just one face of
the surface too you're just talking
about the outer face yes this is just
the outer face yeah
so if it's really really thin then the
inner surface area would be the same
so it's almost like doubly infinite so
if the inner surface area is the same
when i poured in that pie liters of
paint
hadn't i not automatically painted all
the surface area
that's the paradox i think i tried to
think about that and there was like
i think that's the paradox it's quite
neat if you're really into your
your technical maths it's quite neat
because it all relies on the fact that
the volume
looks like one over x squared and the
surface area
looks like one over x that
it's that is the key because if if
you've if you've done
a reasonable amount of maths perhaps
university level
1 over x squared so when you're doing an
integral you're adding together lots of
pieces
and if you add 1 over n squared
forever you get pi squared over 6. it's
called basil's problem it's a very
famous result
but if you add one over n forever it
diverges
it goes to infinity and so gabriel's
horn in the painters paradox
is basically encapsulating the whole
behavior
of one over n squared converging as a
series
versus one over n diverging
well i'm sure you won't be surprised to
see you can take this fantastic
interactive quiz about none other than
gabriel's horn
here on brilliant which is today's
episode sponsor
it's really comprehensive as you can see
this is part of brilliance
calculus in a nutshell one of many
courses on the site
it covers all the classics have a look
at that
it's fun superbly designed as you'd
expect
if you'd like to check it out along with
all the other mathematics and science
and other courses on brilliant
go to brilliant.org number five
there's 20 off a premium subscription by
using that url
there's always great new stuff popping
on the site go and have a look
brilliant.org
[Music]
is to say well because one of the
arguments i've heard about this is to
say
if i made it see-through then i could
fill it with paint and it would look
painted
from the outside and again that's
paradox it just
literally blows your mind